[Music]
hey here we are again ladies and
gentlemen it's tuesday today
look i have long sleeves on yeah it's
cold and
oh my god the microphone fainted
away i don't know what the hell happened
with that oh yeah
yeah all right and my nose is raw those
cold weather getting me when i'm asleep
waking up and feels like my nose is just
like got sandpaper in it meanwhile
people in like the northern half of the
country are being like man quit your
whining
[Laughter]
all it takes is like 50 or 60 degree
weather and it just feels dry
yeah i think it's like when i went out
for my walk this morning at 7 it was 41
it said on my phone
and i think it's 56 now like i think
that's what my
laptop just said before i started it
we're so used to like
very intense 100 percent humidity that
when it gets cold and starts drying out
like all our [ __ ] skin [ __ ] starts
cracking everywhere
make this memory my skin cracks anyway
that's why i have
i have lotion in literally like every
room that i go in like a big huge thing
of lotion because i'm always having to
like [ __ ] do it what's
that in my lips and my hands all the
time we've evolved into frogs we're like
amphibians now
pretty much although i will say that
every time it's like night it's cold
outside like when i went outside this
morning i was like yay
because it was only 41 and i was like
yeah i'm cold it's awesome
it makes me a lot more energetic you
know what i mean because it being hot
and humid here all the time it just like
kind of wears me out and makes me tired
but so when it's cold i like actually
feel like going outside doing stuff
yeah michael's saying that um i had to
leave because i didn't want to listen to
myself
[Laughter]
you know i could see that happening
well you do that all the time you're
just kind of like [ __ ] i'm leaving
yeah
but you don't want to talk anymore yeah
i'm sick of this
and then like i get sick of my own show
[Laughter]
he's sick of his i wonder we're losing
subscribers
no we're not no i'm just talking like i
said we're almost actually we're
get i think this morning we were at 10
087 so we're almost to ten thousand one
hundred yeah
yeah yeah so it's like it's kind of
picking up that's really cool
yeah um but yeah so uh you want to start
talking about this movie because
yeah this movie was a good one i'm so
excited about this movie this is a fake
jollo movie
i did not know that i needed this movie
in my life
until i saw this movie as soon as i
started watching this movie
as soon as it started to [ __ ] do its
thing it's kind of taken me back with
some
kid little kid you know watching cinemax
and hbo
when they had jalen movies on a lot you
know what i mean [ __ ] all the [ __ ]
giallo [ __ ]
gags this thing did it and you're like
yep that's it that's it it's like
it's like the pinnacle all the giallo
movies that you remember all just in one
movie and it didn't make sense the movie
didn't really make sense
it kind of made sense but sort of but
not really yeah so
this movie it's crazy because this came
out way back in 2014
and for some reason i didn't hear of it
back then
even though a couple years ago i was
looking for um
you know to see if like people had made
modern giallos because i know some
people did like
barbarian sound studio is probably the
best known one which came out a couple
of years back
um but that's like that's more a serious
movie
that is set during that time like it's
set in the 70s like in the italian film
industry and it's done in that style
this is more a parody but it's not a
parody
in the same way that like scary movie is
a parody of scream
it's like a parody and an homage and
also a giallo in its own right but it's
making fun of it but not
it's like really hard to it's just a
recreation of giallo movies i mean this
is a mostly american cast as far as i
know
they're canadians canadians but they're
all dubbed like they're speaking italian
it's not
funny and then like it tries to be it it
tries to be as a town so good
it's so good it tries to be as italian
70s as possible they
they put as many [ __ ] nude women as
that they can in it
even dudes like slapping women yeah
around naked women in the background
playing patty cake i mean
you're [ __ ] taking it to the to the
ex
yeah it's just like no one says anything
about it it's just like don't be just
like a naked woman in the back just
because
yeah just because you know and that
because i'm laughing again
and they're all they're all gorgeous
pretty much oh my gosh
like that's totally italian too i mean
you know
italian women or women got into italian
movies just
because they were beautiful yeah ugly
women
had to be beautiful even the ugly
there's another teacher right there so i
wish i was like writing all these days
all right we need to get an ugly woman
back here
yeah yeah you you you know just
beautiful woman you know
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah just put a
black eye on her
black house with glasses on it yeah that
makes glasses
now you're ugly and pull her hair back
in a ponytail yeah yeah yeah
oh my god but so yeah so make sense
though because you know they were
begging them all probably
well yeah so it's not like you're a gun
if i can bring an ugly woman onto the
set there's another good look
well yeah everybody's like well we don't
want to look at your
the [ __ ] you think this is this is this
is italy man this shit's got to be
sexist
sex well and i like that thing we're
paying these women
they really [ __ ] nailed that with
this too this movie
i see okay like i'm not sure like if you
don't know anything about giallo movies
like if you've never seen a giallo movie
i don't know if you'll find it funny
like you'll just be like what the [ __ ]
did i just watch
but somebody that's really into italian
horror really into
you know and and they make like a whole
bunch of like little easter eggs like
particularly like lucio folgi um dario
argento mari bava
they make like all kind of like little
wink nods to it but not in a real
obnoxious way
so if you're really really into giallo
movies you will
i was delighted delighted
by this [ __ ] movie it is just so it
came out like i said back in 2014 i'm
surprised i hadn't heard of it up until
now because
what the [ __ ] universe like why isn't
everybody like
this into giallo movies telling me about
this movie why why why
i'm not even like totally in love with
the alien with y'all the movies but i
like this one because it kind of
it kind of because it takes the craziest
[ __ ] about giant movies and just keeps
showing it to you
you're like yeah here's one thing we
were kind of drink we weren't drunk when
we were watching this but we were like
you know having a cocktail or whatever
i started laughing and when it came on
like because i was like oh it's a giallo
parody i was like i gotta see that
yeah so um so tom said before it even
started he's like this better not make a
goddamn bit of sense
yeah and it didn't yeah well i mean it
kind of does
but but jealous movies kind of make
sense too yeah
they just kind of they force them to
make sense you could tell they're
they're telling this tale as they go
yeah and then sometimes some of those
java movies seem like it might be two
movies that they forced into one
then they kind of like which they kind
of did with this one too and then they
kind of like rearrange it to make a
story but
when it's over you're like is that what
they really intended from the beginning
because that's not a really
cohesive story it's just a story they
pulled out of their ass
but that's the way it always seemed to
me i think they just kind of make them
up as they go along or like
like i mentioned before i think that
it's more a case of
we have like x amount of like cool
looking scenes or
cool looking gore gags that we want to
do and we just need something to like
kind of string them together so it sort
of seems like it's a narrative
they were doing lucha fulchy stuff you
know you know majors were like the knife
coming down and almost hitting the
girl's eye
yeah i'm not sure if it's gonna hit or
not my favorite lucio fulcio homage in
this was
one the tarantulas attacking the person
randomly in the library which i thought
was very funny
also one of the women that gets attacked
but she doesn't get killed and then she
gets hysterical blindness and her eyes
go white
and then in the next scene she has she
suddenly inexplicably has a german
shepherd
just like emily and the beyond that i
was like oh my god you've got to be
[ __ ] kidding me didn't
didn't he somehow he was making a film
or he was looking at film and then got
attacked by a translator and later on he
researches tarantulas in film
yeah yeah yeah something like that to
help him find a [ __ ]
clue to some case he was doing and i was
like yeah that's like some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] the italians would do it back in
the 70s
it's just oh my god it's so something
he's looking for some film
sees a spider get on the film didn't it
burn up
yeah i think wait the film no yeah yeah
yeah
and then somehow it clicked into his
mind that researching the terms
spiders in film we'll find it it only
makes sense in italy
in italian well yeah like i said
basically what the plot of this movie is
and if you go to the wikipedia page and
read the plot you'll just be like
you're like what what but yeah so it's
set up like
like a giallo in the sense that there's
a bunch of murders going on like
somebody's
like all these people around this uh you
know film studio are getting murdered
and the main um suspect
is the editor whose name is rey i think
ray
ciso or something like that it was i
thought it was funny because
the guy the character's name of the
editor in the movie was the name of the
real editor
of this movie so like because i saw out
of the credits and i'm like oh i see
what you did there maybe but um
so he apparently he wasn't he was like
some big deal like
editor back in the day like but he was
working on
a project for this like really like
you know fancy italian director who was
making the world's longest movie
and i guess he like went crazy
and he didn't he like killed his
assistant and then he got it's like his
fingers cut off yeah that's right and
then he was in a paper cutter
in the pa yeah he cut his own fingers
off like in the in the film cutter or
the paper cutter
and then like he was institutionalized
and so now he has like a wooden
he has wooden fingers like it's this
kind of thing that like snaps over his
hand i was like oh that's very jealous
like somebody having like some weird
kind of
uh you know some not not necessarily
like a weird
yeah like a weird kind of prosthetic or
some weird kind of something like some
kind of
deformity or something like that and
it's weird too because it almost at the
end of it
it almost goes into like a lovecraftian
kind of
direction which some jello movies did
like some of them had kind of
supernatural
[ __ ] about them um but not
not usually but some of them did have
supernatural aspects
this one basically goes into like
a dimensional rift type of thing like
toward the end
yeah but i guess i i don't remember much
it did yeah
it started to get kind of twisted i mean
it just had [ __ ] funny
italian tropes man like dude
is trying to be cool as [ __ ] watching a
screening of his own movie
and this [ __ ] hot actress is trying to
like
make out with him and she's damn half
nude and everything and he's like no no
it's not no no you're ruining the movie
and he's watching himself in an action
he's watching himself in an italian
action flick
yeah that was a [ __ ] weird scene and
he he's just
running around shooting in random places
and
you just gotta see it it's just there's
just something about it like i said
i mean like throwing the woman off of
him get off me
it's just and like i said they shot it
it's exactly
exactly right it's exactly right and
they're all dubbed
yeah and it's like even though like i
said this is canadian like i looked it
up i'm like okay like i need to like
find out who the [ __ ] made this movie
because that's [ __ ] hilarious
so it's this canadian filmmaking
collective
um they're from manitoba for christ's
sake which like a lot of canadian
filmmakers are not from there but
manitoba so um they've made a couple
other movies
previously they made they do like kind
of homemade like
indie movies they made one called
father's day they made one called man
borg
which i think was put out by troma of
all things which i haven't seen
but apparently the two guys that wrote
and directed this
uh who whose names are adam brooks and
matthew kennedy
they were super super into diallo movies
because they [ __ ] nailed it
i mean we were just dying i was
dying with laughter like watching this
movie although like i said
if you are not um
really into italian horror you probably
i don't know you might still think it's
funny yeah you would
i i would think you would think it's
funny but you will find it much much
funnier it would just seem like a weird
it just seemed like a weird 70s
like a throwback or a copy of a weird
70s movie
yeah um but it's 70s italian
which if you haven't seen the 70s
italian you you might miss some of the
jokes but i don't think it would matter
i mean everybody's got terrible afros
and like terrible mustaches
and terrible clothes everybody like
every single woman has to like
has her tits out for no reason yeah
there's one excuse me
there's yeah there's one scene where she
just like walks in and her one kid is
hanging out and they're like hey your
tits hanging
oh my goodness i didn't know you know i
mean it's like all kinds of [ __ ] like
that that's that's way italian movies
were and
everything's just sexist and they all
get slapped around yeah like women fight
back and it's just it's just
it's so so funny yeah and it's got like
um
you don't uh use this universation is in
it too
conversations that don't need to be in
the movie they're not there for any
reason
yeah because that's what they did it's
just
i mean i i was talking about it actually
makes me want to watch it again and if i
remember correctly weren't there like
weird things like circular
circular reasoning inside the arguments
between two people where it wasn't
resolved but it
kind of what or pretty much just [ __ ]
about it it's just the dialogue is
the dialogue in certain places is like
dubbed and and poorly written and
delivered in a 1970s style and you're
like well
okay yeah that's the way a 70s movie was
yeah
i remembered at least some of it and
like i said i mean going by pretty fast
when you're seeing it it's it's hard it
was hard for me to remember everything
because it was just it was so stuffed
with
tropes and it was so stuffed with
homages to other movies like i said not
in a real like overt like obnoxious kind
of way like if you were just watching it
and you had never seen those movies you
wouldn't really
like see like you wouldn't be like oh
what the [ __ ] is the importance of that
but the fact that they put it in there
um
to somebody that's seen a bunch of them
like me and i was just kind of like ah
so what you did
oh i saw what you did there you know
what i mean so it's like but
but it has like charms beyond that
beyond being able to just like
you know be like oh that's a that's a
bird with a crystal plumage
reference that's you know uh that's
housed by the cemetery reference that's
some other kind of [ __ ] there
so you know that said
okay so if you're really into italian
horror if you're really into giallo
movies then you really really have to
see this
and i don't understand like why why i
never saw this like it came out like six
years ago
and like i said specifically i was i
really really like even modern movies
that are that are done in that style
there's not a lot
um even the love witch which um was on
shutter this is on shutter as well they
just added it
the love witch is actually it's not i
wouldn't call that a giallo movie but
that's
the look of it kind of looks like a glo
movie because she was trying to make a
movie that looked like those old
like technicolor movies from the 60s
that was kind of more like a
supernatural like a witchy
culty type of movie but it had some
giallo kind of aspects to it like just
in how it looked
even though that was supposed to be set
in the second in the modern day but then
it was like really anachronistic
like she had like really old cars and
like old phones and stuff like that but
everybody else had modern [ __ ]
somebody says it's on to be also oh is
it yeah
oh okay and uh somebody said yeah love
which
is on uh it's also on amazon prime yeah
yeah cause i'm pretty sure i saw it on
shutter um but i don't know if it's
still there anymore but this they just
added it
because like i said the other day they
just added like a shit-ton of
actual jell-o movies they put like seven
or eight like mario baba movies
um they put [ __ ] uh case of the
bloody iris
they put like a whole bunch of you kind
of like lesser known ones which i
thought was really cool
so the fact that they put this one up
there i was like man i got to see this
[ __ ] and it's just like
it was good like i said i want to watch
it again it was just i found it like
really really funny but like i said if
you don't
if you don't know anything about gel or
movies or care about italian horror or
anything it's like
you might still find it funny but i
think it a lot you wouldn't get a lot of
it and i think it's like much much
funnier like it's a much richer
experience if you do
like know that and like i said don't pay
attention to the plot nobody's good
because it deliberately
is super super convoluted and doesn't
make it all that much sense
but they did like really good gore
effects it's like just ever it's just so
so funny it's like they really [ __ ]
nailed the [ __ ]
and uh yeah so i really really recommend
that one um
i think they added a new movie on
shutter a french one maybe so i don't
know if we're gonna be reviewing that or
maybe
if we can't find another one we'll
probably be reviewing that one tomorrow
like a haitian zombie movie
yeah i think it's like a haitian time
maybe we'll see we'll see if that's any
good i'll watch the first few minutes
uh because it's only got they must have
only just put it up because it only has
like three
skull reviews yeah you know what i mean
um so yeah i guess we'll uh
wrap this up for the day so we'll be
back again tomorrow talking about
another movie
so as always thanks everybody for
dropping by have a good rest of your day
and we'll see you again tomorrow bye